you guys I'm so excited
we have a private screening for the new
Little Mermaid
and I'm so excited for all the kids
Khloe Kardashian shares part of her
hosting an over-the-top screening of
Disney's newest movie The Little Mermaid
for her daughter true I love it the good
American founder shared a sneak peek at
the event on her insta story including
the theater which was stacked with
goodies for true and all her friends and
cousins look at all this stuff how great
hi guys
we're talking Little Mermaid Lego sets
Ariel dolls flounder and Sebastian
stuffed animals and of course it
wouldn't be a Kardashian party without
lots and lots of balloons we all want to
be cute over here okay Coco caught the
moment true saw the mermaid themed
spread for the first time
immediately after they picked their jaws
off the floor
the girls screamed a moment the reality
star says she wishes she caught on
camera we had fun also there Chloe's
sister Kylie Jenner who admitted she
cried through the entire movie A man was
drowning I had to save him this
obsession with humans he has to stop I
want to know more about them I love it
and Coco she loved it too giving a
special shout out to Melissa McCarthy
who plays Ursula you can't live in that
world in this you become a human
yourself it's not even possible I feel
like it's more modern than it was in the
original
just in terms of really carving out the
life you choose to have for yourself and
I just think that's so relevant and
necessary for today that I think it's
going to bring people a lot of Joy Coco
wrote you have no idea how special
tonight was Halle Bailey you are
absolute perfection thank you everyone
in the movie was pure magic of course
Hallie plays Ariel in the live-action
film
[Music]
amazing to officially be a Disney
princess I mean I think that it's
something that we have all just had in
our dreams I just am really grateful to
be in this position when E.T chatted
with the actress she explained how she
feels knowing little girls are inspired
seeing her on the big screen it's been
such a beautiful moment for me to be
able to see the reactions of the babies
it makes me just emotionally overwhelmed
honestly and I cry as soon as I watch
them because I think of the little girl
that's still in me honestly and it heals
that girl inside of me and to watch them
feel like they have representation and
someone to look to to know that they
deserve to be in those spaces too is so
important so yeah it just makes me cry
anytime I see any of those videos
[Music]